Clément alors Clément est avec nous
Clément évidemment c'est Clément
s'incrus sur Europe 1 tous les matins de
6h à 9h30 du lundi au vendredi à force
coucher tôt à quelle heure tu te couches
je me couche j'ai pas trop d'âge je me
lève à 4h mais je peux me coucher à
parfois à 17h et jusqu'à là 56
là je risque de piquer du nez pendant
l'émission
alors on a retrouvé un extrait d'un
auditeur qui ne comprend pas trop par
exemple les questions que vous lui posez
avec Clément c'est très drôle voilà ce
qui fait que les mots le matin
salut toute l'équipe bienvenue à toi
c'est du combien toi
92 j'ai vu ta colombe était du
combien
tu souffles tes bougies à quel mois
en mars en général
au début
le 16
tu viens de te réveiller pas du tout
les avoir on se marre bien le matin
c'est un peu le principe de l'émission
ça part en vrai dans tous les sens vous
nous appelez il se passe tout et
n'importe quoi et vous gérez tout le
monde n'est pas réveillé quoi
à 6h ça va et les auditeurs aussi vous
en avez beaucoup et ils sont ils sont je
sais pas ils réagissent comment le matin
il y a de tout en fait c'est une
émission on a une bande de pente autour
de la table que j'embrasse d'ailleurs on
les a vu il y a Sandra Cohen qui est là
Fabien Delettre
Julie son Pesti j'ai une bande autour
c'est comme un repas de Noël en fait on
rigole on se marre parfois on s'engueule
et comme à Noël il y a des cadeaux parce
qu'on offre tout le temps les cadeaux
alors vous vous engagez aussi contre
toutes les sortes de harcèlement vous
avez créé non merci Michel c'est les
formations pour les entreprises pour
lutter contre le harcèlement moral
sexuel les agissements sexistes mais de
manière drôle en fait moi je l'ai fait
j'ai fait les formations comme ça j'y
suis allé tout le monde s'endormait et
on a créé un truc hyper drôle c'est en
fait je suis avec une psy on a fait ça
avec des avocats et je le fais comme un
one man show je débarque et on pose des
questions il y a des équipes mais l'idée
c'est de d'aborder ce sujet qui est
finalement parfois on commet des erreurs
sans le faire exprès pour beaucoup de
choses à corriger c'est une éducation en
fait il y a beaucoup de petites choses
et on va vraiment s'intéresser à ça
c'est de se dire sans le vouloir il y a
pas un harceleur type en fait c'est on
peut tous à un moment voulant faire une
blague au collège ou même 10 minutes
avoir une comportement que celui d'un
harceleur et c'est en étant vigilant à
tout ça en faisant notamment cette
formation là non merci Michel on se dit
bah ça te va je la ferai peut-être plus
en 2023 comme j'avais il y a 20 ans on
m'a raconté les formations Clément et
pareil que c'est à la fois hyper sérieux
et en même temps à mourir de rire donc
franchement c'est avoir c'est quelque
chose merci à vivre à vivre toutes les
entreprises qui vont le recruter
maintenant
je voulais aussi qu'on votre spectacle
j'hésite oui alors ce spectacle
spectacle interactif sur le thème du
mariage oui c'est un vrai spectacle moi
j'ai c'est vraiment ma vie j'ai 39 ans
et demi je suis en couple depuis les
années mais je ne suis pas marié et
j'arrive pas à me décier savoir si c'est
un truc génial ou une énorme bêtise je
vois dans vos regards déjà j'ai la
réponse OK et le public à la fin de
votre pour savoir si je dois me marier
ou pas donc il y a des soirs on me dit
vas-y il y a des soirées on y va jamais
vous savez quoi s'il y a beaucoup de
divorcés dans la salle ou pas
elle est psy donc elle hésite aussi tu
vois ah oui d'accord donc c'est toujours
pas tranché en fait vous avez travaillé
vous avez failli travailler avec Eric et
Ramzy c'est les débuts de radio mais ça
c'est pas vraiment passé comme prévu je
crois moi je suis un enfant d'Europe 2
justement je voulais c'est la radio qui
m'a donné envie de faire la radio
j'écoutais au collège au lycée et je
suis arrivé on m'a proposé un premier
stage sur une autre radio avec Eric et
Ramzy c'était mes idoles absolues je les
ai croisées je leur ai fait des vannes
et tout j'étais vraiment je devais avoir
18-19 ans et ils m'ont dit mais tu es
trop drôle viens avec nous on ne prend
en stage c'était le plus beau jour de ma
vie je suis arrivé à la radio donc le le
jour dit et je suis arrivé en bas ils
m'ont dit ben en fait ils viennent de se
faire virer
j'ai failli réaliser mon rêve mais j'ai
fait plein d'autres choses après alors
Clément oui ne plus anciens
téléspectateurs de TPMP connaisse
évidemment bien sûr on a des séquences
savoureuses car il y a 10 ans vous étiez
connu dans l'émission comme étant
Clément l'incruste quand vous appelez
comme ça votre personnage était un
stagiaire qu'on pouvait apercevoir dans
plein d'émissions c'est ça
extrait d'un petit film c'est une
association qui propose qui vous propose
d'accueillir des étudiants des lycéens
et étrangers
[Rires]
du soleil attendu ce mercredi après-midi
avec des températures maximales qui
atteindront les 19 degrés entraînement
ce mercredi matin pour les hommes de
Francis Gilot qui prépare la 36e journée
Guillaume Hoarau lui est en face de
riatisation tout comme Henri CV bon
anniversaire encore à notre consultant
les Allemands veulent discuter stratégie
et ça tombe bien François Hollande veut
avancer sur le dossier cette
contre-offre permet d'abord de mettre
2006 il n'aura donc pas les moyens de
peser sur la décision des actionnaires
alors on ne sait pas vers vous va
avancer le gouvernement c'est très drôle
etc
on le doit surtout rire de Cyril
derrière quelqu'un
sur une chaîne un jour et je c'est mon
premier interview de comédien je dis oui
c'est un spectacle vraiment très bien et
2 minutes après je me promène dans la
rue et je me fais arrêter pour un
micro-trottoir est-ce que vous préférez
le beurre demi-sel ou doux et quand on
me dit je disais quelle chaîne c'était
la même et à peu près le même jour et je
me suis dit il y a un gars qui va zapper
comme ça qui va voir le même gars oui je
suis comédien oui j'adore le beurre et
je me suis j'adorais que 11 ans on soit
sur toutes les chaînes on se dit
toujours mais le médecin là et tu vois
je meurs de foot mais c'est voilà mais
pourquoi le gynéco sur France 2 et que
après il est et c'est parti là donc
j'allais sur toutes les chaînes j'ai
peut-être fait des incrus d'ailleurs
dans vos émissions et quelques années
toujours poliment je dérange jamais
je venais avec différents costumes selon
l'actualité c'est énorme et vous faisiez
beaucoup rire et puis il y a quelqu'un
que vous connaissez bien qui vous fait
une surprise aussi avec nous en direct
alors là je vois la tête de Clément
on va parler Fabien de l'aide qu'avec
moi tous les matins j'ai peur j'ai peur
des surprises
merci d'être avec nous en direct
évidemment quoi animateur du Morning sur
sur Europe 2 comment ça va
ça va très bien je suis content de
m'incruster moi-même dans une actu de
Clément il faut aller dormir Fabien il
est tard demain on a une grosse émission
demain on offre des téléphones toutes
les 15 minutes
la marque à la pomme c'est 15 minutes 3
minutes je vous couche en 3 minutes
t'inquiète j'espère non bon Fabien vous
êtes l'un des plus anciens
collaborateurs de Cyril c'est ça bon
quel souvenir genre quel souvenir vous
en regardez comment vous êtes connus
racontez-nous
on s'est connus dans la rue
on a l'impression de faire du bateau
c'est très agréable
quand on découvre mamie tu es où mamie
on est là mamie bon appétit
on vous voit à peu près on voit une
photo de vous deux le matin évidemment
Europe 2 vous la voyez la la photo qui
s'affiche Fabien et Cyril ce n'est pas
moi
c'est voilà
racontez-nous bon comment vous avez
connu Cyril les souvenirs que vous avez
raconté j'ai connu aussi à la radio
parce qu'en fait à l'époque il
travaillait à rire et chansons et moi
j'avais attendu dans la rue en fait
alors sans mission était à midi donc moi
je me suis dit ça va être un bosseur je
connaissais pas encore
à mon avis il va y être vers 9h et en
fait de 9h jusqu'à
que j'ai attendu et je vais un mec tracé
à l'arrache j'ai le temps de regarder
est-ce que je peux travailler avec vous
et comme personne ne travaille avec lui
et bien j'ai eu cette chance moi de
démarrer dès le lundi c'était vendredi
donc dès le lundi j'ai commencé avec lui
et maintenant ça fait 18 ans qu'on se
connaît 18 ans que vous connaissez bah
on va vous sortir des extraits parce que
ça vous a plu beaucoup évidemment est-ce
que vous vous souvenez d'un énorme pour
me fou rire avec Eddie Semoun lors d'un
jeu qui s'appelait y a-t-il un prof qui
s'appelle Daniel est-ce que vous vous
souvenez de ça est-ce que ça vous dit
quelque chose
le but était d'appeler une école et
d'avoir une Daniel au bout du fil
oui bonjour C'est
pardon je vous appelle je vous avais
parlé immédiatement Daniel
oui bonjour
Pierre Palace
excusez-moi on est plusieurs
ah merde
c'est génial et d'ailleurs grâce à
Clément j'en ai encore à nouveau parce
que c'est vrai que c'est assez rare
d'avoir des fou rire le matin et
monsieur Clément il faut le dire je sais
pas il est trop modeste il est trop
modeste non mais c'est des mots
extraordinaire que j'ai vécu avec Cyril
et en plus Cyril il est à la vie comme à
la scène et Clément c'est pareil donc
c'est vraiment deux personnages avec qui
c'est un bonheur de travailler
bienveillance comme il aime à le
rappeler Clément et puis fou rire
rigolade et plaisir est-ce que c'est
vrai que vous payez en veste en cuillère
au-dessus c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai vous pouvez mettre au singulier en
une veste
bah oui parce que avec Fabien forcément
on a déjà fait beaucoup de beaucoup
d'émissions fabien est un très bon
auteur également donc je connais un
petit peu les dessous de leurs histoires
à Cyril et Fabien et il y a des choses
mais rocambolesques il a des histoires
rocambolesque concernant Cyril même sur
des jours tu sais où Fabien où il
fallait vider les lieux et genre vous le
faisiez mais vraiment limite quoi alors
effectivement on travaillait dans un
bureau où la personne venait juste
récupérer le loyer en fait en c'est le
système vous savez que quand on joue
quelque chose il y a loyer à payer c'est
qu'en France c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et au moment où la personne est
venue en fait Cyril m'a dit il t'en
double fait une Fabien tu as cinq
minutes tu prends tous les cartons et on
se barre et on se barre et on s'est
barré j'espère que depuis le contentieux
a été réglé ça fait 18 ans on verra bien
on adore raconter ces histoires là dans
les entends je vais vous sortir un
nouvel extrait si je vous dis qu'il y a
eu un énorme fou rire à cause du cochon
d'inde d'une auditrice est-ce que vous
vous en souvenez c'était dans le matin
sur Virgin Radio il parle anglais je
crois
en parler anglais derrière c'est le
cochon
[Rires]
[Musique]
vous allez tous rester avec nous on a
quelques extraits encore à vous montrer
extrêmement savoureux le Zap aussi de
pas avec tous les meilleurs extraits des
émissions que vous avez vu ces dernières
24 heures c'est à suivre et puis on
reviendra dans un instant sur ces images
vous n'avez pas pu échapper la visite
d'État de Charleroi et de Kamila du
moment parle et ça cartonne à tout de
suite